[Música]
[Aplausos]
para lograr las metas cada ser humano
debe superar diferentes logros y de allí
parten tres preguntas que en algún
momento de nuestra vida nos hemos
planteado dónde estás hoy dónde quieres
estar mañana y que estás haciendo para
lograrlo estas preguntas nos obligan a
realizar una introspección sobre nuestra
vida presente y futura para alcanzar
diferentes anhelos o metas que no hemos
podido obtener en uno o cualquiera de
los ámbitos de la vida sea profesional
emocional o personal ya que en muchas
ocasiones buscamos liberar nuestras
responsabilidades alegando que tuvo un
mal día por equis razón justificó un
error cuerpo a terceras personas o peor
aún no tuve tiempo de realizarlo entre
otros aspectos que nos vienen a la
cabeza y es ahí donde radican los
cambios de actitudes que nos conllevan
al deterioro pequeños logros ya
alcanzado
en cada uno de nosotros hay diferentes
esencias que nos llevan a forjar nuestro
destino y es ahí donde se ve la magnitud
de las buenas o malas decisiones
lo mejor sería pensar que estoy haciendo
para cambiar las tendencias y conceptos
que nos pueden frustrar una decisión o
peor aún una nueva historia por
consiguiente como lograré posicionarme
en una meta a corto o largo plazo fácil
primero trabajando fuertemente en mi
crecimiento personal y enfocando bien
mis objetivos para no perderlo de vista
por ejemplo ser un orador te ha sido un
nuevo reto ya que exponer y vender una
idea ante un público exigente resulta
difícil no sólo para mí sino para muchas
personas y es por eso que estoy aquí
para demostrarles que todos podemos
romper diferentes barreras descubriendo
nuestras capacidades que muchas veces
tenemos e ignoramos y no potenciamos
como lo resolví aplicando cuatro
sencillos pasos persistir insistir
volverá a persistir y seguir insistiendo
hasta haberlo logrado en estos cuatro
pasos no hay espacio para la palabra
desistir y así podremos optimizar mejor
los resultados
creer en ti mismo fomentando el
positivismo la auto confianza y la
seguridad así podrás decir dónde estás
hoy dónde quieres estar mañana y que
estás haciendo para lograrlo suerte
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]